les familles fort
francfort/new doublant le crédit d'impôt
pour la condition physique des enfants
nous aiderons les parents à des foyers
les coudes garderie bonification de la
prestation universelle pour la garde
d'enfants transférer jusqu'à 50 mille
dollars en revenus du conjoint à celui
ayant le salaire le moins élevé
alors si certains doutaient encore que
la campagne électorale est bel et bien
lancée bien les annonces d'allègements
fiscaux pour les familles de stephen
rapp eux aujourd'hui mais surtout le
décor dans lequel ces mesures ont été
dévoilées aura dissiper tous les doutes
tasha daniel michel bonsoir
alors on peut on lui donnait sa stephen
rapp eux il a tenu promesse donc avec
cette mesure de fractionnement de revenu
pour les familles c'était assez
controversé ça faisait deux des bottes
achats il y ajoute d'autres mesures
d'allègement fiscal est ce que c'était
politiquement habile selon vous
absolument c'est non seulement
politiquement habile mais c'est
intelligent dans les circonstances parce
que ça reconnaît que pas toutes les
familles ont les mêmes besoins il ya des
familles où ça fait du bon sens vous
partager leurs revenus et à d'autres ou
peut-être s'ils ont moins de bénéfices
de cela mais ils ont un enfant en
garderie où il bénéficierait encore d
autres bonification ainsi que la
bonification de la prestation familiale
et je pense que le gouvernement essaie
vraiment de se faire un petit rire un
terrain très clair ils sont en faveur du
choix parental en reconnaissant que pas
toutes les familles font les mêmes choix
tandis que le npd c'est en faveur du
modèle gouvernementale le choix de
garderie par exemple et ça laisse très
peu de terrain pour les libéraux alors
pour les conservateurs c'est très
politiquement habile justement daniel a
dit oui c'est très habile il ya pas de
doute là dessus et surtout à le débat
sur le fractionnement va être un débat
si difficile vaut mieux le faire
maintenant que le faire pendant la
campagne électorale j'ai ça stephen
harper l'a compris son fils qui profite
aux familles ce qui profite aux plus
riches il faut dire clairement il ya
aucun doute à tuer tout ce qu'il a
annoncé aujourd'hui
h à raison il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vont applaudir qui vont être très
content sauf que il ya un besoin
désespéré nouvelles places en garderie
au canada il y en a pas une seule qui
sera créé avec ça l'écart entre les
riches des pauvres pas s'amenuiser avec
ces mesures là non plus sauf que ce que
stephen harper a compris c'est que son
électorat et depuis qu'il est au pouvoir
depuis neuf ans s'ils venaient à peu
pensent d'abord à son électorat sur
l'électorat c'est la famille
traditionnelle avec un conjoint qui
reste la maison avec des enfants qui
sont encore jeunes qui vont à l'école
c'est ces gens là qu'il vise
électoralement si c'est très très habile
à il faudra voir et vous n'avez encore
rien vu doit d'avoir cette deuxième
disait ce matin il ya 16 milliards de
dollars qui étaient dévolues aux
différents ministères à ottawa et qui
n'ont pas été dépensés depuis deux ans
il a une tonne d'argent dépensée à
attendez vous à tous et est très
rapidement et à des élections devaient
rapidement aussi me répète mais c'est
vraiment toute cette question des
surplus ce qu'on va faire avec tout cet
argent qui va être au coeur de la
campagne michel quand même tâche elle
disait daniel aussi il ya les canadiens
vont avoir un choix assez clair là entre
deux visions celle de stephen harper on
l'a vu aujourd'hui donc le choix donner
de l'argent directement dans les poches
des canadiens alors que thomas mulcair
annoncé lui plutôt un programme national
de garderies oui il est clair qu'il ya
deux visions de l'état et de la société
qui se pose de façon diamétralement
opposées mais voyez c'est très habile
parce que et quand on regarde les
chiffres
céder à l'insulté studio a
évalué que dans les deux provinces qui
en profiteront le plus les ménages qui
en profiteront de plus sont en
saskatchewan et en alberta
si vous additionnez ces deux provinces
s'adonne 42 comté dont 40 sont
conservateurs actuellement et ceux qui
vont en profiter le moins c'est surtout
le québec alors les familles qui se
qualifie vont avoir un gain de 13 150
dollars à peu près en alberta et 500 $
au québec pourquoi cette différence là
et là on en arrive à la vision très
différent de la société c'est simplement
parce que il ya beaucoup beaucoup plus
de femmes au foyer proportionnellement
ou qui travaillent beaucoup moins en
alberta et en saskatchewan qu'au québec
alors avec cette mesure là on renforce
cette vision sociale on incite davantage
finalement les femmes à rester au foyer
alors on fait d'une pierre deux coups on
plaît à des comptes et des régions
électoralement conservatrice et on plaît
aussi à des gens qui sont
idéologiquement conservateur tâche âge
va réagir oui parce que écoute je suis
d'accord avec michel son analyse que oui
ça plaît aux comptes et en alberta et en
saskatchewan où on retrouve des familles
qui ont 7 ce modèle plus du traditionnel
les fous aussi savoir la raison qu'ils
peuvent plus la voir c'est
économiquement les emplois tu es
beaucoup plus il ya beaucoup plus de
gens qui sont employés le taux de
chômage est beaucoup moins dans ces deux
provinces là ainsi c'est beaucoup plus
facile d'avoir une personne qui peut à y
gagner assez pour faire rouler une
famille tout seul au québec en ontario
ce n'est pas le même cas mais si les
parents avaient la possibilité de faire
un partage de revenus il ya certains qui
pourrait faire ce choix qu'ils le font
pas présentement parce que justement ils
ne peuvent pas économiquement alors ça
veut pas dire que les gens n'ont pas
d'appétit pour ce type de solution à
garder leurs enfants qu'il ne préférait
pas ici on demande aux parents si
j'avais le plat possibilités économiques
de faire le choix de garder des petits
enfants de bas âge à la maison au lieu
de les mettre en garderie la majorité
dit oui mais c'est quand même une
délicieuse conservatrice ce sont des
valeurs très conservatrices non
tranchante et moi c'est une c'est une
vision conservatrice mais c'est aussi en
faveur des enfants écoutez si vous dites
que c'est bien que des poupons des
jeunes enfants bas de trois ans ont tous
mis à la garderie et déclin d'études qui
disent que ce n'est pas le yacht et
d'études qui disent que ça ne change
rien et la tâche parce que tu
t'aventures un intérêt qui saigne à
l'école il ya une étude très bien c'est
de l'université de montréal là dessus
qu'ils font moins bien à l'école s'ils
ont mis en bas âge pas après l'âge de 3
ans mais en bas âge à la garderie
missionné c'est quand même une réalité
au québec le programme de garderies est
un énorme succès justement parce que ça
permet quand même beaucoup de femmes
d'aller travailler à plus de femmes
d'ailleurs de travailler que dans les
autres provinces c'est de se dire on
s'entendra peut-être pas sur cette
question-là
s'éloigne un peu notre sujet daniel way
non moi je veux bien vous aider je suis
échauffé d'accord avec michel lis avec
vous là tu marché du travail les femmes
n'occupent beaucoup plus au québec à
cause du programme des garderies en très
bonne partie mais là où on peut revenir
à notre sujet principal si vous me
permettez là aussi ça devient
intéressant c'est que avec tous ces
milliards on n'a encore rien vu stephen
harper va s'arranger pour occuper tout
le terrain pour qu'on essaie
complètement des deux partis
d'opposition thomas mulcair jusqu'à
maintenant des solutions de rechange
intéressant son plan national de
garderies qui coûterait 5 milliards le
relèvement du salaire minimum si des
mesures intéressantes et justin trudeau
à peu près tout ce qu'ils nous ont dit
jusqu'à maintenant sur l'utilisation des
surplus c'est que 1 il va y voir évoquer
les baisses d'impôts dès que des
conservateurs il deux peut-être investir
dans les infrastructures
non je suis d'accord avec toi si tu as
chaud là dessus mais il va devoir
étoffer son programme dire exactement je
veux faire quoi avec ses milliards là où
on va les dépenses et ils pourraient
tous les donneurs 1 du canada serait
très content mais ça n'arrive au report
mais il ya urgence pour lui de dire et
très rapidement parce que moi je pense
que les élections seront reviennent
rapidement de dire qu'est ce qu'il va
faire avec ça sinon il va être
complètement débordé par sylvain drapeau
mais d'achat ce qui peut vraiment annulé
d'abord parce que les gens vont y avoir
accès c'est un peu difficile difficile
non ça va être très difficile et même
les [ __ ] indiquent qu'ils vont
maintenir les prestations augmentent et
bonifié de 160 $ pour les enfants en bas
âge que les conservateurs amène parce
qu'ils savent que la minute que tu met
l'argent dans les poches c'est très
difficile de le retirer et pour justin
trudeau justement je ne suis pas
d'accord que le npd est coincé par cette
mesure au contraire je pense que
justement au québec oui c'est vrai les
garderies c'est populaire alors l'un des
des accès de vision étatique des
garderies ça vaille plus populaires ça
va les aider au québec c'est les
libéraux vraiment qu'ils ont de la
difficulté à trouver un terrain entre
ces deux positions des deux parties qui
sont très bien étoffé de mon avis est ce
que ça peut être embêtant quand même
cette mesure ce fractionnement du revenu
michel au québec ben c'est embêtant pour
le gouvernement du québec c'est très
embêtant je pense pas qu'il s'harmonise
parce que ils perdraient de l'argent
mais mais ce qui est encore plus
embêtant c'est que il sera absolument
pratiquement impossible de récupérer ce
champ fiscal la hausse avec 1 quand
monsieur peut annoncer qu'il y aurait
des baisses d'impôts me concerne pas
exactement comment ça se fait monsieur
l'état au ministre des finances du
québec avait dit on pourrait peut-être
en profiter pour occuper ce champ là si
le fédéral se retire mais là la mesure
de fractionnement et tellement cible et
qu'on voit mal comment on pourrait
arriver à récupérer cet argent là c'est
beaucoup trop pointus ont fait pas dire
dans la loi de l'impôt écoutez ça va
s'appliquer seulement aux familles qui
ont tant d'enfants puis que l'écart de
revenus entre les deux c'est alors c'est
pas possible donc pour ça coince les
provinces mais quand même dans notre
réputa sondage la civis écosse on voyait
que quand on donne aux canadiens ce
qu'on va faire avec les surplus qui sera
donc cette grande question ben y'a
seulement 16% des gens qui souhaitent
une baisse d'impôts chez les partisans
conservateurs ses 28% seulement
et 6 28% de très loyaux conservateur est
cité à ces gens là que que stephen
harper à penser aujourd'hui c'est sa
base y'a un stephen harper depuis qu'il
est au pouvoir jouer avait peut être
très bien traité sa base lui a donné à
peu près tout ce qu'elle voulait sauf
sur des questions comme l'avortement ou
y a pas bougé mais ce 30% là va être
très heureux de ce qui est arrivé
aujourd'hui
il y aura d'autres mesures qui vont
encore venir servir cette bataille à 30
à 35 % de gens qui sont aux prêts selon
les sondages lui ou moins à voter
conservateur et c'est ces gens là que ce
qu'ils veulent un peu besoin de rassurer
maintenant consolider cette base là et
essayer ensuite d'empiéter sur le
terrain des néo démocrates et des
libéraux
sacha j'vous laisse terminer là tu es
rencontres à sanaa 30 je pense la grande
question va être un autre est aussi liée
à l'appétit pour les coupures d'impôt
ici on l'a pas vu au provincial
l'élection lors des dernières élections
provinciales mais je pense que quand les
gens ont l'argent dans les poches c'est
différent et les mesures conservatrices
ont tous un tout s'est pas séparé
baisses d'impôts et crédit et tout ça
c'est tout vous les dents une balle je
pense que quand les gens ont l'argent
dans les poches ça va être plus
difficile de contrer cette mesure pour
les autres partis très bien alors
j'aimerais qu'on parle un peu de pierre
karl péladeau qui est encore fait les
manchettes cette semaine on en a parlé
c'est votre journal qui nous apprenait
michel qui aurait l'apparence du conflit
d'intérêt au sujet d'une baisse de 2,2
crédit d'impôt en production visuelle ça
fait plusieurs semaines que ça dure et
comment est ce que pierre karl péladeau
peut maintenant mettre comme on dit le
couvercle sur la marmite michel babin
une chose est certaine céline c'est pas
faisant des farces plates surtout eto'o
et en menaçant de poursuivre en évoquant
la charte des droits que monsieur
péladeau va régler le problème on
l'avait dit précédemment moi je pense
que monsieur péladeau doit faire un
geste lui-même
d'abord il doit se demander très
sérieusement s'il veut vraiment faire de
la politique et à partir de ce moment-là
prendre les moyens pour avoir un peu un
peu de marge de manoeuvre parce qu'il
faut pas se faire d'illusions là ça
s'arrêtera pas cette chose là tant que
monsieur péladeau lui même un rapport
mis de l'avant une solution qui va être
jugé acceptable pour par nécessairement
les libéraux les cas qu est-ce qu on
comprend très bien qu'ils ont avantage à
faire durer le plaisir mais qui va
satisfaire dont la majeure partie de la
population actuellement et je pense que
ce qu'on veut ce à quoi on assiste
semaine après semaine des nouvelles
apparences de conflit d'intérêts ça joue
pas en faveur de monsieur péladeau
daniel quand même su péladeau dit agir
non pas pour ses intérêts personnels les
intérêts que des corps mais pour
l'intérêt de tous les québécois je
regarde aller depuis qu'il est lâche 7
comprendre à quoi il joue et mon
impression et c'est vraiment juste une
impression c'est que il c'est pierre
karl péladeau que il va gagner la course
à la direction du pq les sondages
démontrent il est seul dans cette course
là et le pq sait très bien que c'est le
seul qui peut remettre le parti sur les
rails à partir de ce moment là péladeau
se dit je vais tester le système je vais
aller jusqu'au bout du système
voir tout ce que je peux faire dans ce
système là à moins qu'il soit rennes à
effet qui est pas compris comment se
joue la partie politique mais moi je
crois pas ça je pense qu'il sait
exactement ce qu'il fait et le moment
venu quand il deviendra chef du parti
chef de l'opposition là il pourra s'en
remettre à une fiducie sans droit de
regard
mais encore là le fiducie sans droit de
regard après tout ce qui s'est passé
moi j'essaie de m'imaginer le matin ou
le jour où quebecor ramène pas une
équipe de hockey québec est ce que
monsieur péladeau comme moi et comme
vous vous l'apprendre dans le journal le
matin fiducie sans droit de regard c'est
souvent très perméable tâche a quand
même la course à la direction du parti
québécois allait lancer losc il faut pas
qu'ils règlent ça parce que sinon ça va
ça va ça va ça va traîner tout le monde
la course oui risque de venir le
berlusconi du québec sans les partis de
bang bang or rappelle non mais le
problème de d'avoir un contrôle ou une
influence même justin su exercer une
influence sur les médias à ce point là
c'est un grande question qui devrait
préoccuper les gens non seulement dans
la politique mais aussi en général parce
que effectivement les médias sont le
filtre pour les politiciens la façon de
les garder comme on dit en anglais du bo
c'est à dire que garde s'assurer qu'ils
font leur devoir s'assurer qu'ils qui ne
font pas et qu'ils n'enfreignent pas la
loi par exemple c'est très dangereux et
je pense que c'était une grande qu'un
grand débat qui doit se faire il devrait
régler aussi tôt que possible et on
n'entend pas beaucoup le particulier
quand on a entendu jean françois lisée
mais on n'entend pas beaucoup le parti
québécois là-dessus michel en terminant
quelques non non on les entend pas on
les entend pas et pour cause d'abord les
adversaires de monsieur péladeau ont vu
ce qui est arrivé à jean françois lisée
et ils veulent pas hypothéquer le plus
de chances que qu'il leur est peut-être
en attaquant et en ayant l'air d'être
un mauvais choix pour le parti et ceux
qui ont déjà il y en a beaucoup à
l'intérieur du caucus qu'on les voit les
lits sont pratiquement plat ventre déjà
devant monsieur péladeau qui sont
tellement certain qu'ils vont être le
chef qui n'ose pas le contredire même si
écoutez je comprends qu'on essaie
d'élargir le débat mais je pense que
tout le monde convient avec le
président de la fédération des
journalistes que le problème auquel on
fait face maintenant le sait pas un
problème général l'indépendance de la
presse ou de concentration de la presse
c'est le problème qui est posé par un
magnat de la presse qui veut faire de la
politique c'est ça le problème les
autres problèmes existaient avant puis
que vont continuer à exister après c'est
celui là qu'il faut régler très
intéressant on va s'arrêter là dessus
merci beaucoup à vous trois merson
prochaine